boom Bel Air season two baby is a quick
rundown of everything that's happened so
far this season will return to the
mansion after Uncle Phil apologizes to
Ashley's birthday party and sweetie
pulls up to him you know that's kind of
cool then will breaks up with Lisa oof
Hillary bosses up in her influencer
group Jeffrey was also kicked out of the
Mansion but he and Uncle Phil make good
Ashley's teacher misused AKA Tatiana
freaking Ali gets fired for teaching
outside the curriculum so the BSU
Carlton and Will stage a protest to help
get Miss hughes's job back Carlton's
anxiety gets the best of him and will
ends up the school hero this white dude
named Drew comes into the picture
stirring things up with Carlton and even
starts eyeing Lisa
basketball team so he joins us AAU team
and runs by the dude named doc Mr Banks
Crossing has nominated for the founders
award but so does will
Carlton Society spikes again I'm bill
has an art gallery that everyone loves
she's great things heat up with Will and
Doc's niece Jackie sorry Lisa Hillary's
relationship is on the rocks for jazz
and her ex the Marcus comes back in the
picture the worst possible time Jeffrey
reunites with his son Frederick Will's
World shakes up again when he finds out
doc isn't what he thought he was and
Jackie knew all along Uncle Phil plans
to save his company by teaming up with
Erica Baker but on babe obviously
doesn't trust her backstabbing ex-best
friend and Carlson relapses hard with
Connor and starts lying to everyone
including what you told me this isn't
what you think which leads us to episode
10 the finale and you all know we had to
end things with a bang so make sure you
watch because you'll never believe what
happens next
[Music]